people here in alcala say they are
burying a hero
neri abelos died while rescuing his
neighbors from flood waters
using his own boat but his daughter
angela is angry and is calling for
justice
she says her father didn't have to die
from electrocution
if only power lines were disconnected
early enough
while typhoon vamco was hitting the
entire philippine region
of luzon
justice justice where was the village
captain
where was the police my father wasn't
any of those but why did it had to be
him to rescue the residents
none of them showed up they found his
body two days later
typhoon vamco was not meant to be this
devastating
now days after the typhoon's truck the
government is facing widespread
criticism
from people here they say the tragedy
could have been contained
with more able leadership
kagayan was not even under a typhoon
warning when vamco hit
the capital region it was only
experiencing moonsoon rains
at the time more than 80 000 people had
to be rescued in this town alone
widespread deforestation has long been
blamed
for constant flooding here too
makeshift shelters like this one are now
visible along the highways of alcala
and nearby towns civilians who have lost
nearly everything and are in desperate
need of aid
inside this small tent there are five
families who have to endure nights
sleeping on the ground with their
children
our house is still underwater so we just
have to stay here and cramp under this
tent
we're grateful for any help they once
had rice fields and comfortable homes
now this is all they have left typhoon
vamco only hit the region of luzon for a
few hours
but it left a trail of destruction and
suffering
jamal allendog and al jazeera cagayan
province northern philippines